i know i'll take heat for my opinion on
this as a female but in large part he's
right um we're going to play it people
some out there won't like it i don't
care let's play it
uh this is the eighth [ __ ] now the
reason 18 and 19 year olds are more
attractive than 25 year olds is because
they've been through less dig i'll say
this right here on the [ __ ] internet
i don't give a [ __ ] people will sit
there and go you can't say that yes i
can a 19 year old is more attractive
than a 26 year old woman and i'll tell
you why because that 26 year old has
talked to more guys been to the club
more times been more places been [ __ ]
and dumped more times more arguments
more heartbreak more [ __ ] more mess
for me to clean up whereas a 19 year old
might have had one guy from high school
just broke up she's fresh and i can
[ __ ] put my imprint on her make her a
good person and without her having to go
through all that detriment to learn
about life so what's your key age range
19 it's not it's not just about the age
range
i mean one thing i will say where i
think he is wrong here is i think that
the vision of a 19 year old who you know
oh she's only been with one guy that's
not the case anymore you've got 19 year
old women who have been around the block
i mean more times than i have today as a
43 year old i mean it's wild the
promiscuity has bled down to a very very
young age bracket so you know i came out
of i always tell my story and i remember
talking to adam and adam saying you're
an outlier you can't use you as an
example but i came out of college i had
been with one guy you know one guy that
was my experience that was important to
me that was what i prioritized talked to
girls coming out of college now good
luck finding a 19 year old who has that
same way so i think his perception of a
19 year old is actually not terribly
accurate for this moment but but i think
the larger point of saying
that a woman is more attractive the way
i interpreted what he said is i said
okay a woman is more attractive if she
has been more selective has had more
self-respect hasn't been around the
block a million times hasn't given away
the goods too easily and has saved
herself for experiences that matter
women don't promiscuous women modern
feminists may not like that point but
that is a reality and i think that for
men that is something i know my husband
has had that conversation with me many
times that he very much appreciates the
way i chose to live my life that was
very valuable to him so
this is another example where
immediately and you know who gets
offended rollo i'll tell you women
who've slept with everybody on earth
hear this and they're like what what is
he saying about me take a moment and
self-reflect yeah he's talking to you
and he's probably right
yes well he's he's right and um okay so
what he's really kind of kind of dancing
around is what i call the alpha widow
dynamic okay what that means is that
women imprint upon the guy who is the
most alpha dude that is in their sort of
their the guys who they've had sex with
in their notch count okay so a a girl i
mean technically speaking and i
understand i completely agree with you
because i've been on freshman fit where
i've been sitting next to 19 year olds
who have a 15 to 20 body count already
at 19.
they are upfront and open with it all so
they that's what they're saying so i
agree with you however i will say this
is that we've had these um these
episodes before i've done them on my
show i've done them on freshman fit
where we talk about the importance of
women's promiscuous like how why is
promiscuity still
uh important to guys today even in this
environment even in today's society well
the the the alpha widow dynamic it goes
something like this is as the more
men that a woman of men that a woman has
been with over the course of her you
know her sexual history
the of the more uh
let's say the the more chance like that
so the greater the pool of guys who made
that imprint upon her or have given her
that baggage so the more that woman has
slept with those guys the more
i mean just statistically speaking the
odds are if she's got 10 or 20 in her
back field
one of those guys or three of those guys
made an alpha impression upon her that
the guy who's next in line is going to
have to overcome because he's got to out
alpha the guy that is like sort of the
ghost of alpha's past right and so
that's the that's the idea so i i always
say this it's not so much a numbers game
as it is like an alpha impact game so if
you've got a woman who's got like three
prior lovers okay and you got a girl
who's got 10 prior lovers but the girl
with three had one or two of those guys
who were just like the most alpha guy
that just left her when she can't get
over she pines for that guy he's the one
that got away and you're the next one in
line and you've got to find some way to
outclass that the memory the fantasy of
that guy or would you rather be with a
girl who has 10 and none of those guys
really made all that big of a deal were
all that big an impact or maybe their
betas or maybe their one-night stands or
whatever and you're the guy who can very
easily come in there and form a
relationship with that woman because she
has not she doesn't have any real alphas
in her back field so it's really an
alpha impact game it's rather than a
numbers game however
odds are that if she's got 10 most
likely one of those 10 is probably going
to be the guy who's like she just can't
get over that's what he's trying to
describe here but everybody once they
hear this they say oh
what's your age range they want to turn
him into like a pedophile they want to
turn him into like
a a youngster you know you're uh that's
why we have this concept by the way of
um like was half plus seven like you're
you're not age-appropriate you're not
with a woman who should you should be
with you should be like a guy who's 30
should not be with an 18 year old a guy
who's you know 40 should not be with a
28 year old whatever i know whatever the
age range happens to be you're still an
adult she's an adult you're an adult so
it's like you're consenting adults so
why why would that make any difference
well it doesn't to guys but it does for
women because women age out of the
sexual marketplace and that's what rubs
them the wrong way another unflattering
truth
about the differences between men and
women that they're being reminded of and
it makes them feel bad at the end of
that conversation so you know from
talking to me you know we sat together
and that i don't like promiscuity either
way i don't like it in women i don't
like it in men it's i'm very deep into
self-respect for your body so i don't
like flippant sex that's just not
something that i think really helps
anyone long-term that's how i feel about
but i'm curious your perspective do you
feel though that you were talking about
you know different men who can make an
imprint on a woman for example
throughout the years do you feel that it
could be the reverse as well like it
could there be a guy then who dated or
went out with you know 10 women 12 women
and got hurt
several times along the way and now he's
got all the baggage and that becomes
problematic for the woman in his life as
opposed to a guy who had been around the
block less times has less baggage does
it work both ways in your mind
uh i i would say no and i'll explain to
you why because men do not place a
as as
they don't place the degree of
importance upon sex as women do simply
because simply because women's
biological nature
is to invest emotionally in the guy that
she's having sex with on some level if a
woman doesn't do that like say she works
in the porn industry she has to be
trained and conditioned to sort of put
her emotions on hold and say this is
just a sex act this is just i'm just
doing something with my body it's like
sports right
for men that the reason why guys get
addicted to pornography is because our
innate uh our innate sexual strategy is
unlimited access to unlimited sexuality
and what provides that vicarious
porn pornography that's why it's free
that's why it's streaming that's why
it's 4k
so when guys are thinking about sex we
can dissociate ourselves from the
emotion from the emotional connection
that women inherently innately evolved
to have because having sex in our
evolutionary past meant that that woman
could possibly get pregnant and if she
did that could be a death sentence even
if she picked the right guy she has to
emotionally invest in that's why women
have much more uh a much more proclivity
for like sexual revulsion that's why
they are very much more selective that's
why they are they get quote unquote
gatekeepers of sex right they have they
have a filter for guys who are creeps
they have a filter for guys who are like
the hot guy that they the op the good
opportunity is just as
as just as important as the guy who is
the creep who she just wants to simply
stay away from it's a it's a biological
neurological mechanism of women's
psyches to invest more emotionally and
personally in sex because they are the
ones with a higher reproductive cost for
men it's you know we the the wind blows
and we get a hard on right it's the it's
we have to hit it and quit but uh what
what john say it was uh ejaculate and
evacuate and we had to do that because
we had to be very efficient
opportunistic breeders in our
evolutionary past as a result men do not
have the same emotional investment into
sex that women do and that now okay so
take that and fast forward that to 2022
where we're having this conversation
right now and do you know do men not
have like women that they pine for or
think it's their soul mate yeah until
the next girl comes along and rocks
their world in bed or or the next girl
that comes around and they she seems
like she's somebody that he wants to
invest in
they do not pine for
women or for for their past partners in
this if they do in the same way that
women do because they have already
created that emotional investment in the
guy who is the best that she can do so
if it's like oh he's the best that i
could he's the one that got away even
katy perry has like some song called the
one that got away yes or if you look at
like the end of titanic where rose has
the heart of you know the diamond and
everything she's had this wonderful life
from some you know beta provider but she
still can't get over jack who's in the
bottom of the ocean in a icy grave and
at the end of the movie it's like she's
reunited in death with that guy not the
guy who provided her this li this
luxurious lifestyle and grandchildren
and everything else is the dude that's
at the bottom of the ocean that's the to
the point where we're creating mythology
and stories about that dynamic so that's
the difference between men and women
when it comes to uh emotional investment
in sex or otherwise if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]